when hoeneß called me back on the phone
he asked me if we
wanted to record the podcast at his place on
tegernsee or at bayern munich on
säbener straße
and i was really very nervous and it
was about a podcast i chose the same
seats according to the street
we then talked there about his whole
business life but i
didn't dare to ask the
camera team
who could come with me that's why i was the only one with an audi poser
there's only one audio track but it's really something
and it comes
from the same one today  after street soccer
fans know the address and i'm very
proud to have the man as a guest who quali
built säbener street like that invented
municipalities is so
built has good days first of all i didn't build it on
board has you're curious the
former president was himself
building contractor and of
course did not play a major role himself with his
mum and a part of that but
first of all  the extensions were erected
thing i am not jointly responsible for
that runs as rather modestly long then
you can see people allegedly standing in front of it at the time of
day that
meanwhile there are about six seven
building blocks in moments normal
residential area and they were all before
not there all now  huge
thing and that's what we've done over the last 40
years, so from a
small club we now have a
medium-sized group and
sometimes understand how it went
and the first question about it was there
actually some superordinate
strategy, did you say it was strategically
planned, and that was it  a lot of tactics day-to-
day business luck with it or are the
strategy tactics
so the need to know how i got this
job i was
injured relatively early relatively badly
i had my
first knee injury at the age of 23 at the champions league final in paris in 1975 which then
quite a meniscus lost a few
month  e later the second that means
no more meniscus in the right knee
and it was actually already clear that
i can't play football forever a
doctor said before the second operation
so if you operate now
that your career is over but there
others of the opera  said if you do
n't have an operation you'll be closed right away
I decided to
then from 75 to 79 only four years with
relatively big problems on the word
criticism and so on punched
through and so 27 I've spent the
last half year pursuing my career at the  played fc
nürnberg because i had a
problem here with the school lorant
our coach got along and we did
n't get along and i
really wanted to prove again that i know well
and we did. i didn't play that bad at all
but still in the
soon  know that very narrowly relegated
and in this phase there was
quite a lot of
trouble at FC Bayern, yes you have former president Neudecker with you
great theater for the team because he
absolutely wanted to have max merkel as a
coach and the team was not
at all with the climax that
they think they lost an away game in düsseldorf
6 or 7 1 but
here it was total chaos
and in this phase called me one
day  the investor in nuremberg as hoeneß
you can imagine
becoming a manager with us and what's going on
and i say i have to think about it for one night
please talk to a couple first
my knee still works
well the boys says never long and
then i have the next  promised that day that
was in march april '79 and then i
started here on the first of may at that
point in time today had already
resigned under the successor the
former treasurer revoked
me but then and so i
started and you should know at that time i had
20 employees today  almost 1000
and we had 20 million marks in sales
and 7 million in debt and you have
to do that too  you know you've always been
very business savvy you can
read about it that as a
player you supposedly got at least one offer
from real madrid and said i ca
n't switch there because i earn in
munich in addition to doing business with
somehow giving autographs and all
kinds of more than we do  back then with riis
could have paid
that the same time once paul
breitner both had the offer 74 after the world cup
that the economic was nothing
or important point would like to work
all in one
without a lot of work of
course be able to earn more but i
sympathize  22 not ready for
abroad and as i just told you
when i was 23 my knee was pretty damaged so i couldn't get an engagement in real madrid or unfortunately unfortunately no longer on the other hand i was of course okay with the serious injury if i wasn't anymore  can play football for a long time
must
think about it from the moment  what will i do
after that because a trainer job was not an option for me it
was always clear that i would
try to give management a go
. i had four years to look over the shoulder of
robert schwan, who was also the manager
of franz beckenbauer
and in
all
foreign games i always confessed when he checked in the hotels
when you play friendly games with the opposing
danes in peru in bolivia where we make
friendly games why the
team to refinance there i was
always next to the month always kept my eyes
and ears open around  to learn
but still an actor from the early
days to understand how you might
think at least interesting that you
allegedly drove back to the top at least as a
youth national player somehow to play in ulm
and then wrote articles in the local
newspaper about
the games and  you
actually wrote it down as an editor
for the time  ung back then me it's
not so normal now that
you say okay i'm a youth player
or ask the editors write
about my own games but it
was a bit of a special ambition yes i've always tried to think outside the box and continue to
do so
to create an article to
describe it brings little money but a
lot a lot a lot is let's see what's
possible no hackers if you have to
and then deal with it you have
to deal with it and you're
right that I've always tried to take a
look  to throw up front and that
was of course how i saw my
job here at bayern you should
know at that time fc bayern was a big business
with a turnover of around twelve million marks and
85 percent of these twelve minutes were
spectators meanwhile have
little to do with
the whole business  what I then tried
to build up with it marketing merchandising
all these things that today for 82 70
80 85 pr  ocent of our income
make up that I have of course
built up actually always
build up your club you build up several start ups in
one there is exactly there is
merchandising now a topic there is
then all the content where we are
very strong exactly there you build
one  various companies all on
what was then the first thing going on
against bavaria it was first the merge
however hardly believes it still
before letting what i did the
contract only german cities advertising to
terminate because the german cities camera
planned advertising nationwide for  all of the
clubs made it and of course they
said if I said
sell a gang again in a smaller club
then we both have more than one stone and
you get one too and as a result
they got more money for the small
club and that had to be changed
than we did then  alone we could
say we sell the one in the
olympic stadium and so on and so fo  rt
i brought everything back to
bayern right from the start fc bayern
didn't have any marketing staff at the time
because everything was outsourced to some strange old
tours and that worked out for
me i flew to america
did something with the san francisco before
the niners  learned from the san
francisco giants who
flew to manchester to manchester united who have always
been strong in merchandise
somehow had megastores and so we
had a post office here with a few
scarves a few coins or postcards and
when jürgen klinsmann came to us we
started out at least wearing real jerseys
for sale in the order of over
a million pieces and i
looked at it all over the world and
so slowly but surely we got everything
back with all rights and then
marketed it with our own people and
now we have had a wonderful marketing a
merchandise all
just have to leave it supposedly
lederhosen  which he then undressed with this
famous song so it was
all somehow the invention
to do something like that or at least there
is even the story that they
allegedly invited fans from a
düsseldorf ice hockey club to the stadium
so that they made the determination
at that time he took over  state not like that was
n't such a good idea because documents are
n't sour
because as
i
said we
let ourselves be determined  the
brehmstraße the legendary
mood tactics but that was that but
what were the focus on
ours also had thoughts
and then got better but
at first it was about whether
to create a mood here he had above all
things you have to do that  someone
came along who said damn
it, soccer, it's nice but important
, empathy is important, emoti  on and that
was of course important and if you are
our stadium today if it's sold
out 75,000 then we have an
outstanding
atmosphere it's been counting since 2 a.m. in all stadiums is getting
much better now i don't see anything
in the highest sentence that we
really what  as far as the mood was concerned, it was
really good because it seemed clear early on
that a path to success had to be very
strong to emotionalize and also to
polarize, so it was deliberately the
core of the brand connoisseur idea, so to speak, to
say that someone here has to
polarize i don't think I
would
I had planned to rent but that was down to me
personally. I've always expressed my opinion.
I also marketed myself. I did
n't have an adviser, neither did Paul Breitner.
We were buddies here, we played together for a long
time and I don't think it
was like that for me now  here from every
morning at breakfast I've thought about
what I'm going to get out of here, but
that was often i  st can sometimes before well
sometimes got a little too
boring then around the club you've been
provoking for example yes but I
mean when we played werder
bremen was like usual in the
team I put on
what was going on yes or or with  then
when he was really good at leverkusen and
before that in stuttgart
we provoked the shop because when
he was provoked he made mistakes
that was also part of the team
pushed forward so that we could get along well
but it was always like that  the
idea of really creating a brand so it
really became a brand
with a claim and everything was back to the r
ght brand we wanted or I was
't arbitrary either you were determined we wante
an an independent brand
is a that can't be confused at any time yes e
eryone  knew knowledge
in bavaria it says bavaria in it
is particularly painful for you to
see that nowadays not
t the clubs are
supposed to decide that way the players themselves we have become
so if I
can only really speak about our team right now
if we have to if all the clubs
and intelligent is so clever
guys like us then that’s not a
problem of
course  I honestly used to be
able to announce more and say
that we're going to do that now, exceptions
today you have to be more discussed, so
there were counter-arguments
and if you happen to say that then what's
wonderful I have to honestly say at the
moment  what i have seen is how confident
our team is on the pitch but
also off it
is pure joy i mean with
guys like joshua kimmig with leon goretzka with
sabri with manuel Neuer also about dosky
on his he has they have a clear
opinion
but  the most important thing is if you
open your mouth, i think that's good, but
then you have to do the performances on saturday
and that's what they bring and if that's the case
open your mouth and don't
perform well then that's the problem but if you say your opinion very clearly position yourself
and then really get involved
especially show hunger until the end tired
ideal condition but anyway that's how it is
now  the players have a lot
more power in the end the fans come into the game
as a result no longer the club or
i wouldn’t see it that way it also has to do
with those responsible in the
clubs it’s a question of
authority i think of course i have
to admit that  the consultants and you
have a great deal of influence
but if you understand his
players and, above all,
take them with you to explain the big picture to them,
then i don’t see a problem there,
but i have to say it has
become more strenuous, you could
have, you used to  what has been said and said we will
fly to tokyo tomorrow or next
week if we war a
million there  gen and
then they also grumbled but they flew with
you today
you probably have to discuss it for some time today
but
you should never make a feather let them fly there don’t fly with them
yourself and say goodbye at the airport
until the day after tomorrow they
’ll come back then you’ve got it  the
revolution but you have to be the
first to march ahead as a leader that many demand but
you are the first to get on the
plane and the last one to leave then
there is a good chance that you will
join in that i was about to ask
you at the end  yes, fc bayern is also a
performance principle and no
club of germany’s ministers has managed
to be so strong over so many decades
in all areas, including sporting in
the end but economically
why what did you or
your colleagues invent or create as a management principle at that time
no one if you can copy what is
what the hint  ergrund so this
performance principle has yes which breaks
it down so what are the 34
crucial hints go ahead and
have now understood what is still
difficult to talk about yourself
but i think i can only guess but
i think our big advantage is that of
course we have
a  good brand bavaria is a great
country munich is a great city it's
a great prerequisite if you
're somewhere and that and someone in tokyo
knows where that is then
difficult the second is and that's
i think that's the main advantage
we've succeeded  to
manage the last 30 40 years
with relatively few executives and thirdly these people
are both in a position were former
players great personalities and they
have no idea about the economy
i think about it karl heinz rummenigge
also at the beginning paul widener franz
beckenbauer not of course and the
herbert is done former players
like gerd müller like sep  p maier like
hermann gerland like many in the
clubs to integrate hans flügel into the
club, for example, and in
addition we got top people in our marketing in
our merchandising part in the
long run and they
always let go which has led to us being
like this  we were successful and of
course we had the advantage that we
always made the right decisions at the right
time i am thinking
of the allianz arena for example
if we still do this today that olympic
city granted fc bayern not fc
bayern is increased but what do you think
how  we had to fight
offers with the edmund stoiber as prime
minister i have once in the
administrative assets must not
forget the fc bayern has more
fans than the csu voters
or
i had a royal
argument he will definitely get the olympic stadium
resonated but that would have been
a disaster  so far in the roof
but i always know them before just
novem  about at 10 4 - the people should sit on
the opposite straight and
freeze their butts but now
i understand a lot of the element so clear
power structures permanent also
constancy in the power structures in the environment in the
stadium now let's take it i'm
in the ruhr area you know  gentlemen
that's also quite good why
didn't it work at all at schalke
firstly i think that many
many what i am exactly the opposite
many different people have not tried in the last 20 30 years
but that was always there  but
he doesn't know that much about football now, so he
decides to discover very important players it
has turned out and that
's not a criticism of him at all that many
subcontractors have to
understand that football is
something if, like i guess, they have
children in hannover  very one of the best companies
in germany but
it just doesn't make it that he's from
hannove  r there was no power because
i think you have to
have played football at a certain level to
really see through and, above all
, to be afraid of the players
when i say with a player
what should we play together again
that's nice but it's nice
then  accept that it's scary but
previously played
in the a-class
east westphalia there thinks that i
what does he actually want a lot more
that he likes how to do the
instep yes that's a big
advantage believe me and also in the
media if  i talk to a journalist
and criticize him because he has a
completely different brain from our game than i
do then i have to bring the
substance into the discussion
but i can only do that if i understand something about
it but do you believe that players
also have respect for a long time  just
people have made an entrepreneurial
career like the wieder kind
or like you in berlin windthorst come
to the conclusion that the sp  Many people end
up having almost more respect for a winter like that
because when he comes into the dressing room
and talks about football they say
well you have to look at it with his
ankle his money back in berlin
do you think that markets are stronger he has
something else  he thinks
that i don't want to talk about others
not basically it's
totally fine that investors that's
also the future for one or the
other freelancer but what exactly is
the reason in berlin they have to have everything
i don't know because i've never dealt with that
I've been so busy because that's
one of those things a lot of people always talk about
others I've been involved with
Bayern Munich all my life and only
when FC Bayern was attacked
did I defend it and then of
course I talked about others
but I would come  never have the idea to
presume to say to
me now in berlin or in hamburg then
I would have to do this and that it will be better there because i have to i  ch myself would first have to
do an analysis of what
is the environment like willi tick this free
how do the people there tick and after
that there might be a concept but from the
outside now to be so arrogant as to
say what you did wrong in berlin
the trust  I don't think so,
but the investment
probably can't be
recovered because you don't have a club like
that
that was
n't the fact that investments for the
price was able to buy a whole new castle
from the better one no because they
also bought it towards the hall but then
it would have started because
they don't see themselves as a good team either
but they are on the relegation zone
that is now a problem that three too much
money flows that is a problem
because of course it is saudi money and i think
so  be
with that the premium is going to get a big
problem because saudi arabia is
not exactly a country where
human rights are particularly well done
and at some point they will dance around like [ __ ]
and stuff and be happy that all the
money will go to kassel fans well
you don't have to everyone  like but is
it generally the case that if you were to
invest now, then it would be better for
a family or a Bundesliga club
after you would have
to fight against states in Bremen is here
I would rather
invest in the Bundesliga because I think
clubs like hsv should, for example, if  if
you really tackled five six people
you could
make something out of it yes that instead of
just being great the environment is
absolutely right because heidi hamburg is the only
city if it were managed well because of
which i would be afraid
you are really making progress  because when you see the circle i can
still say that it's
hard to see from the outside but i mean it's
definitely ma  nagement mistakes so many
yes for 30 years
so then please say reetz adamek
is already ordered back then it was
champions league
and what did he do ex footballers
already understand footballers okay but is
moved again by my theory okay
but if we now look at who is last
somehow built big
teams that is of course now or in
madrid the boss because the strength figure but acute
advisors he
has because the manager had good trainers
that's okay but with a
crazy economic effort yes and
debts and that's an important one too
what we
are proud of at fc bayern shoulders that we have
this success that we have
now built so high over many years
not without the word that is a
whole lot of people who do it not
one but many and if you
see now that we  have a new
management structure and nevertheless
football continues to be played well
because both at d  He put an incredible amount of thought into the selection of
the people who are supposed to do
it
and I think that we also had the one in
the relationship we had at the
moment as an exotic person at the top of Europe in
top-
flight football has total costs Mr. Perez next to him
always has former
top french international player said paris
should find out about fc bayern one day
it's enough the greatest praise we can
have but in the end despite the fact that it was more difficult to
hit it seems
like we're going to play against them tomorrow
i wouldn't have had a sleepless night
before really not really
because of the heat  smoke and mirrors when
i saw them against leipzig
i thought to myself they weren't the
worse team well
it would make sense for them that
the bundesliga go with the 50 plus 1
topic so then it would
n't even have to be at least as a competition
prevention give the whole
concern maybe relaxed
a  lso who from FC Bayern we have a
self-limitation of 30 plus one but
we have a deal with our
members under great pressure from the
members who do not want us
to sell it to any people
we are very happy with
our three shareholders and that  is the
alliance that is another kind of audi
i say yes with triple
the 25 percent own fc bayern
we made a digel with the
members we have at least
300,000 that we said
we can sell another five percent
without asking them and  if we
sell more 0 5 percent than 30 percent
we would have to ask the members at an
annual general meeting and to do that we
would need a three-quarters majority to
sell more, so in my view we
wouldn't get it, so who is the first to
ignore the two if I
now talk about the rest  league
i would be inclined to say 50 plus 1
abolish so that the
others like the others  have the opportunity to
prove that if you get more money
from other shareholders
or if you become more competitive from the outside
i would like to see this experiment and the
arguments are fc bayern is
against it because then it would have more competition
i don’t see it  because i
don't see this as a problem for bayern munich
i understand, for example, i understand that mr
watzke
is still totally against it
, he actually only owns 15
percent of his boss, even though he chose a
construction, so although he has the
majority of the votes, he has the
capital  had already sold far more than 50
percent if you
come back now if these three top partners
have always bought shares over the years
i think the first to
buy was that they got this value back
then from around 1.2
billion  as a rating, 120
million have been given in the club because it's
not sad nowadays when you see
d  as it has only proven itself from
1.2 billion now look what
human suffering is worth on the stock exchange
more towards 3 billion and
FC Bayern was worth much more today
I have you when you make
such decisions you
always have to judge the point in time  on which you make
a decision back then the 120 was a
lot of money to me today they are
less but i think we would if we sold them
we of course
also have a buyback right from adidas and
that is not much higher than 120
so we will look for another partner
then we could do
reibach but we don't intend to do that if
a partner from bayern munich who
helped us in difficult times
will not be kicked out by fc bayern
if he's doing well and what space even
with the three that's a four or  five
Japanese is not conceivable yes we
can only sell 5% here at the moment
so one of the five percent will
buy now would be likely  not
difficult but that's
only necessary if we absolutely
need money and really want to go
so far that the
spectators can come again which we
all hope then I don't see any germs
although no danger that FC Bayern
absolutely  capital we are a
club from your point of view the three
most important employees what are the three
most important jobs in its mean football
group
first of all it is of course the
chairman of the board
then
the chairman of the
supervisory board is no question world the
supervisory board is relatively powerful in our company
and then of course there is immediately
sporting area the
board responsible for sport in the case hasan
under trainer so this your players
including me again are of
course always crucial but for 44
to come to strategic decisions
the players namely the questions
and trainers are, so to speak, the four
people association of the four  didn't
mean people  n
chairman of the board chairman of the supervisory board chairman of the board of directors for sport
and of course the entire board of directors the
chief financial officer is with us when we make every
important decision it's
not like
lonely
people made decisions here it's crucial
i say again and again if you
like me to be more specific we and like him
means the board is important of course the
chairman is a bit more important
than the rest but if you are smart you take
your team with you and we
have been so far in dresden a very important
man became an incredibly handsome man
is and that is why we are in this
position  well cast sometimes
last year 30 years than 40 years
you see what you say the 23
turning points okay that was
crucial that stalin was certainly
a very important for us was also the
turning point in germany political turning point 89
because we had that back then  70 60 70,000
members and the moment the
wall a  then it all went off
there were many who lived in the east
suddenly came out
as bayern fans then we came over
100,000 we didn’t advertise at all
they are still in
demand training camps
that was also a strategy to
come to them  who can't come to you
, yes we did, and
then we deliberately did great training camps
two or three in the east and that
was an outstanding thing. There were
thousands of spectators during the training
and I made
the fan articles together with mannes flugler immobil  20,000 1 goes
again have a training session
then it was big is halo but he came
and snatched the whole player
away like everyone at
leverkusen the top players he
didn’t get the hackers for us no question
but we had made a decision
that we  not to buy any players from the east during this phase
because we didn't
want fc bayern with their
coal to  se poor clubs tell me
sold yes that was a conscious
decision
that means sometimes it is
so clear with you fc bayern has to win
and that is the performance principle but
behind that at any price exactly where is
the limit so you do them too
completely decide yes we will
then decide on a case-by-case basis we don't have a
full manual as always look it up you
have to do it other universities
have done it or
the management consultants have told us again after the night according to the law of probability it is
so
if something happens you have to sit down
together and make a decision and that's how you
can play st pauli in hamburg is
also legendary by now these
rescuers that's what do you think was going on
before when we always came to
the millerntor  always
been
thrown at with coins i was doused with beer once all hell broke loose
and after this board game he b
if i had been celebrated there i would have sent you
the championship but
why did it i mean that
if you show so much hate
why do you say yes because i always but
i like a club where tradition and
passion plays a big role and  despite all the
willingness to attack us, i
always liked how these fans and these
employees also partly conny
littmann this president the madman
in a positive way
how we loved your club with all our heart
and in good times and in
bad times i thought mr wolf
when we  now would descend for
two days if we
didn't get the stadium full of course and
i liked that and as a sident
therefore can have a sensible key
against them how you
apologize and part of this this
strategy was fc bayern comes to
these pictures what  he brought in over two
million with tv broadcasting and
i was immediately on fire
un  d quite apart from the fact that st
pauli is of course not the only one free
don’t say
i would say 80 percent the club
has always been happy with our money at some point
yes we also
lent them two million at the time when
they could no longer pay their
salaries ok but it is  on the one hand
chosen the timekeeper admit but it
is still the case although
[music]
pointed to earlier michael meier
we have calculated but he was then
[music]
gaps in memory in vienna area but
that is also good for the brand so
i don’t play in rostock or in
cottbus because it's good for the brand
but primarily if we
wanted to help people because we wanted to help in this
structurally
weak area so that the
injured can be played through football
that's the
crucial point and or a club
the sc freiburg den  By the way,
I don't think we helped because
they always helped themselves, that is
also a club like that if it got into
trouble gameday i would
fall down 100 times because it i love
this club because they because they do everything so
great emotionally modest and with
hard work and i would like to
have the pranks you haven’t we have  we
discussed it for a long time
but didn't have the courage in the end because yes
I just know it would have gone well because there was
another risk for us he says he has
Freiburg but the and the people for
how he actually loves players like
he loves them too  there's no question there has to be
fire that's amazing
when you say that even at the end of
the football nostalgic where the fans
are that like that they're in the
second league always in the first league is
now full of clubs where that's not
that's exactly how it is and but i have to say i have no sympathy for the
clubs that are down there and i have a
lot of respect from the lesser-known
clubs with ih  ren modest
means he has made it
if someone like paderborn like
bielefeld is seduced for them if they make it
into the first division sportingly i take my
hat off and respect
that was because eg what i always say wunderlist
on one side is totally
like you  do and appreciate that
on each other there is of course then
before that against yes but at that time
for example
we had a television contract so FC Bayern took a
bit of money out on site is that
not true we didn’t cost anything in advance
but we  we told
them people
there are two options
we do the individual evaluation
then fc bayern is rich and you are all poor
or we do we do
central marketing we agree or
at the beginning we should do this
individual game there were paypals juves or pay per
view  and we had that
guaranteed by the church and
when, after nine months,
the others ceremonially stated  have that 70
percent of the people's games only
bayern managers hand and we had of
course earned so much money
and served the less we
abolished pejril but we had the contract
that was the problem
[music]
one of our regular partners here
is called text txt
rotex like the tax and texts is
appropriately the compliance platform
for the digital economy very specifically
, texts help to process if you
sell
abroad then in
other
european countries you already need a sales tax registration what sales tax is
all extremely complex
for several countries to pay for many
products  and that’s exactly what
you take away from a text, so from the small amazon fps
dealer to larger shops, texte lends a helping hand, of
course, the
workload for the respective
tax consultant is much, much less, they
can easily
handle 50,000 transactions in the country, or
maybe even more  ubri needs
help  gens also retrospectively maybe
no text or tidying up helps
there are of course also interfaces to
erp systems to all relevant
marketplaces from amazon to ebay and so
on and a shop system the colleagues
see you as interpreters between
the world of e-commerce and the
complex world of  regulatory or
something like that if you want to know more if you want to do
texts because you also want to get
involved send a short email to
pr text you should get a discount at the end of the
day the first three months
free of charge basic package you save
at least 90 euros per month
[music]
if you watch  that you are true which
ones you should have set up and also how
you always put it on systems
merchandise very early on also
marketing very early on
why is
digitalization not such a central
topic for you personally was you didn’t enjoy
it so much it felt so digitalization
these  Topics don't interest you like that
, that's pure coincidence,
basically
important that you do that of course i will not want to
prevent anything anymore
will
we have 50 or 60 people in our department right now
so we are online day and night at
my house my wife does online
banking more have a computer
my office only me  I myself have an apple
cell phone and I only make calls so that you
can send me an sms but there
are the legendary faxes but they don't want to
receive e-mails so it's
amazing you know why if
first of all it was of course also at the beginning
whether it was your son's convenience  but later
i see a lot of my friends and so or if you do that for
three days then you
have 200 e-mails the time of which
is 85 percent weak yes and the time you spend
on it
and i'll say again the few people
who are my first  I'm yes I'm
online via my wife via at the
office everything important in the world comes
to me you can even get to us
for what's what your s  tars your players
and we don't have them that's always
amazing when i come to
dinner you have it again that hey
what's nice is then we
have to tell all of it and it's so
entertaining
yeah i don't get it at all
but i think before fc
bayern collapses then do
n't call but it's possible
to understand the new paid you also have to understand
what's going on there and how the
family face basically you
're absolutely right probably you have to
but as time goes on
will in the end be
the ones who do little that were the empress do
you really mean yes if i now have
these new topics i bring
mine i am for example
realizing that i am completely
calm because i garnish the thing
but if i have many  friends or something like
that you look at your
mobile phone or your computer
for 60 percent of your time then i think i can at the moment
happily doing a lot of sensible things
but it's also the case that
somehow internal team things from
the social media get back into the
team and back and that you
make more sense 80 percent of it
i don't even want to know who knows who knows would just get
upset and then leave  my
blood pressure is high and healthy
are you then on to all these things
tracking for example what nft
is there this company solea
that we heard about we are now making digital
trading cards billion companies of the
start-up this brand in the area is
something what a  pass
me by completely or that doesn't pass me personally but
i hope not at fc bayern can
we have 1000 employees who
spared themselves with this topic yes of
course the supervisory board makes sure that the
big picture
works and we then
have to report at some point whether they to the in
the business makes sense or tokens or
caregiver very much about it is
discussed yes and ic  h I was
some devils doing it to prevent that but
the others should
do that, especially since we take the topic so
bitcoin is sitting well that's something they
say we're only very
interested in economics happy I
'm very skeptical
because yes  but because firstly that is very
controversial yes
a lot of environmental damage because it needs
a lot of content and
secondly
money laundering
anonymity very precisely what we only
our society not necessarily
mafia money drug money is
being laundered I don't know if FC Bayern
has to be there
then there is another problem
that of
course the data from our
fans
will somehow get further
at some point and i guess they are
actually our tenants but i
really don’t want to that’s also the
main problem today is something that is very
important but our fan then i see
not as a cash cow that
wants to sell something that should be in the same
place again  buys on our jersey so
go buy if he buys a pair of shoes from us
football school buy everything but
i don’t want to write a letter every day
i got your address from
there and now we didn’t have to have
a pair of skis or five pairs of shoes,
it should  and my fans
because we play good football
and i don't want to
constantly confront it with things we
absolutely have to buy and
we see the whole gaming so many clubs also
internationally rely very heavily on
online games and then we're also
on the sidelines
I'm skeptical about that too but you see I'm
skeptical anyway it's going to be done I
won't change it I say personally of
course we won't get past the topic
but I still think it's
a shame because because a lot of these young
guys who are sitting at home there now
citizen in hand and one
hand and other hand with your thing he
says play with your mouse
it would be  smarter he would be on the
soccer field would move around and
they say well they are in top shape then
i always say one of the three hundredweight
weighs just as good as one of the 50
kg and
the two of them can't make it clear
and what and it will be them  even sony
does not suggest its beautiful world in such a way
that people believe in the end yes
i exchanged luca toni at
halftime today for xy and in
real life van
gaal also did it once when luca toni was
exchanged  but after
halftime and on monday he didn't come to
training and that's the
reality sees in the
football nations
i was also brought in the
emotions that with this at the time with the
attack department this was
made aware for you to stop  also
to stir up emotions but that he
was not to weaken the competition at
all i always tried when i
attacked 98 percent of the time it was
to protect fc bayern because i still have
maria that i call so close lists
and insults her
when i have the feeling that fc bayern
or parts of the club player-
coach board members were treated unfairly yes
then you have to say something i
have lothar matthäus, for example
fetched briefly what did you actually
tell about the nonsense that fc bayern is
the worst-placed clubs in the bundesliga in the width of the ish
than in the fun-free
yes now she stays living in dortmund and of
course i called you after
our 3 1 in leipzig
he had few arguments and if
you are now experiencing the champions league in
development yes what was the
week going on again and then when i see
that we have a very good
football game from both sides in lisbon i am
then in halftime or the last
20 minutes  what's going on here on the
bench what we then comes the boy in
turn he comes then i think this
loth  ar
there we can explain more that we
didn't shake well in general
but you have fifth, for example,
which we can use at any time
and they have a problem and
then you have to say something and
that's yes or I have it too  called into
this discussion on sunday morning
there should always be
it itches me more often i don't see it
regularly because there is so much
chatter yes and then it really gets down
to business yes and that he's
interested in saying something
with it  a bit of partying but they
just have i got the number 5 from an
editor who since it is under officers
and then he goes over his microphone to the school
management i have the dog then everything is thrown
away it comes live in this
one then it started but it was
natural
the sunday morning
could also be asked but i look at it because they do
something because then it starts but
there are also say so conscious
ones  Breaks where you wrote down exactly
before now that I'm
going to and now I'm going in interviews
or written down definitely
don't happen but maybe more pretended
yes, there are also legendary
examples where you said afterwards
that it was deliberate, I'm sure
but i didn't write everything down in my
head
okay because what were otherwise so to
say we are also somehow
i can say very very successful very clever in terms of marketing
what else is
there the decisive or the most
unusual must you have done like
that i mean ice hockey
to order fans is one thing then
to make the lederhosen to polarize to
build up a brand
but i have its such a crisis
is that there is something which is also a very
important point that we don't shout about the
big bell but the most important
point with the first  the plan is that
i believe that we are very strong in the area of
nability what he is doing today
plays a very important role we have our own
people who take care of it and what i think is
the most important thing i think that
fall into the most social whole world but we do
n't necessarily talk about it you
understand because if in my time
somewhere i can remember there was
this plane crash in  remagen
there weren't 15 workshops and 33
meetings, but we
worked together, we have to help and
then maybe the trainer said
yes, we can
play a charity game in the bundesliga game on sunday
in the rain on saturday and we have to show that
at all  aloofness that football
yes partly that we are human and
that the human being is the little man who has a
problem that has to be helped if it
somehow works you can’t do that every
day but at certain events
or certain occurrences
we’re doing something again now  Unfortunately, for
the victims of the flood disaster
, it has not worked out so far  and
to find reason in appointments but that
's the way it's spontaneous and
not too big placed an ad did
you notice that we're doing it this
way and that but that it's
taken for granted and
I don't think it's for
that to talk about what  so i can say
we've already seen research you have the
foundation board very strongly support the
dominik brunner foundation that he is only
one of six or seven i give all
my income that i just for
for for lectures for when i was co-moderator at rtl
that that  i 56 this
includes the dominik brunner foundation
until that is this homeless newspaper in
munich
then then have the children's dreams then
a foundation in south africa a school i teach a
lot of children school is on
fire sorry that's called then antenna
bayern helps i'm on the board of trustees
so it is  in 56 foundations
that make you happy with all these things over the year or that
of that of christian springer that of that
cabaret  tist he helped orient ev than
with a lebanon the story
he then spontaneously
donated 200,000 euros i also donated money so
just
do something where it is necessary and as i
said all my one and that is very
large income over ten years
income from all areas of the
advertising market goes in this direction or or without
my lectures so when you talk about money
you build a company yourself
from
78 million sales now to 6 700
million sales anyway i was
personally surprised when you read it
could in the context of the tax issue
the thing now you had a lot of private
money you also invested there that
's an insane amount
so there I thought that 1 1 are
also generation of players if they were
25 today then they would probably
earn millions  can with
the profile world champion European champion and
so but at that time it was still quite
small I'm a  ls the Bavarians you
don't stand so much that you can work with
20 30 million duration where
can that actually than first of all
is of course correct that's a
notch in the other hand is the one where I made
a huge mistake ca
n't be like that but  I've always
been
I've always been let's say very
adept in this area of
l markets and [musi
] I di
dn't do it very often besides he was busy
n the end earned more yes o
viously than living room of cours
I have to know I don't know if they are profe
sionals  you can just how
to leverage the bacon or the student over
more yes if you speculate 20 million
you only need 10 percent
one shot yes if it's gone it's
gone then the position is gone too but that's
how it came about and  for a
long time i was very very successful and
unfortunately not anymore after that and my
tax problem
came about in a crazy way i had a lot at the beginning  l
earned money with it in the end everything was
lost again but i
couldn’t offset the losses against the profits
the tax is correct from that but if you make a
huge mistake there’s no question
look at what’s happening today that
you give all the new trading apps a
lot of people  should also be listed on the stock exchange
yes says yes to the
pension plan is good but i am
very conservative in this regard
i still have a manager i have my
capital assets but i am very
conservative i only buy individual
stocks no etf no funds i  I have
two three banks that manage the money for
me but I decide the
rest personally, mostly on Mondays,
who read a lot
myself, consciously tries to spread the risk
when they do, I always go on
a campaign, so today I buy the one
or next week the one I  In
this area, I see
shares in my depot today that have been there for ten or
15 years, yes, I'm there  quite
conservative i keep a very close eye on the high-
dividend stocks it
can't be a secret that i'm a friend of
allianz telekom and so on
but that's not such a bad way
to go they've been through the whole digital
company gold rush a little
bit but that kind of thing  google facebook
unfortunately not for that unfortunately not that
means i said to my son the week
i have a huge amount of
microsoft at 23 they are now three times
before
which where in florida
me and i am i am not either i
am never one of them either  it who
buys something when the car had to be bought is that and
that reminds me because i want to know
what's behind it and so on and
should and what i should never do
companies to buy where i know where i
can recognize ownership because of his knowledge that
's what i have  for example in the at s
share because we say
it will be great but there would always
have been a risk that you
might do it  ch full and that was also
with the lever stories from that
individual titles have adored no
I only bet the world at that time
it was the next appointment it was
n’t about titles but about dollars euros
swiss francs but that was it
now  then he really did
n’t like the Rhine, i was a gambler rheinsberger but
because there are stocks then it’s the case
that you read newspaper articles
or read an incredible
amount of business and business press yourself and of course i have ingo specialists at the various banks
with whom i consult
but nobody can decide  what to
do when he comes down from spain and which
company if you now last 20 years
back you've been making longer played
in most plays so what
was the most successful
title you've made
when you add it all up with by
all means dividend the  alliance the
alliance the suns increase in value experienced
the last one not so much in the bl  ick
okay there they have never
forgotten the profits of 4 5 percent
if you extrapolate that to 20 years
we are already 80
and your own factory especially what you
also know about you moser ex factory
why does my children hear it now yes  ok
but you built and built with
a partner
so
meat producer sausage percent pure hate
this is just what i mean here at has to be
in nuremberg because if you produce original nuremberg
rostbratwurst then the factory has to be in the city limits
of nuremberg because that is one
geographically protected
product
protected throughout europe and then there is
this restriction and so in munich
you couldn't produce any nuremberger
100 million sales not quite too but
i estimate almost 90 85 90 everything
right so songs by is supposed to be from 0
he was saying yes that's one  Entrepreneur
performance again parallel to
ackermann's sometimes although I have to
say since about my son has been doing e  s now
20 years
yes and he made a big
contribution that i
built it up with a partner who unfortunately
then became seriously ill and died later
and when he unfortunately died
i first tried it with a managing director
or two managing directors because
i yes  at bayern it got bigger and bigger
i had less time it didn’t work that
well and then one of
my children had to step in thought first
when my daughter is older she
studied business administration the boy with a bank apprenticeship
at the landesbank did it at the age of 21 and
he’s doing it sensationally and  has
really made a great company out of the company
we are actually going to start now i mean
you could say your parents are older
what history but it is not
somehow from the parental home but
is it really really at zero green
had before yes we had i a
certain  I only
had a clue, of course, because my parents owned a
butcher's shop
and I did  had for another friend
the company rowern is well known your
big company he once asked me
say politics do you know the people from
aldi i want to make a book with them in the 78 times
but what did that mean but germany
the austrians are eliminated and
me  also four weeks earlier was
injured muscle fiber rupture i
didn't know what it was but i could
n't miss anything anyway i then
four weeks after from argentina
caught the book
participated wrote an article but the
book was advertised as a huge flop
germany but the people from  aldi
was obviously enthusiastic that
at the end of the autograph session i still
did all the things that i
didn't have to do and so he asked
me was here asks you do you know the
people from aldi can you help me
to sell better and at some point
i'm me  since we went there we
preferred to buy cheese and so will and after
a while two beginning of the  in the 80s
the buyer told drk can you
original and about rostbratwurst
says no because my factory
design is unacceptable that was
in the back of my mind and weeks or
months later i met my friend
who had not gotten to know the west in
the six months in nuremberg  then when I was
at per
game he got me a little butcher shop and an
Asian restaurant so
and at some point we are here late on his
birthday night seen
drinking a little more then I
say yes to the advanced we say we
were there you make a was big
bratwurst yes  yes how much 50 km 50 kilos
you have to make tons let's make a
sample what is it like then i sent it
to mülheim to aldi south
the buyer said it wasn't so
good we did it again the third one
was
fine as you have credit in  you don't have the factory yet you do
n't invest in the production facility
yet if you give us a chance
what else do we have  never done
then i got rules to the top
purchasing manager from al deficit a
certain one even had it quite researcher said
my purchasing failed they want to
sell us a sausage dont have a factory
we have never done that has always
invested if they gave us the chance  i was little bayern at the time
i could then once a week and
sometime on march
6 i will never forget 85 i got a call at 6 p.m.
in the training camp with the
team played against as rom
and this topic so hoeneß
we have now decided we
give you a chance two warehouses with
all this each warehouse supplies about 60
shops
Langenselbold and Mörfelden near
Frankfurt you have six months then you can
deliver sixth maz
I'm thinking about puking on April 15th
and then I have a week's
vacation at Bavaria there's another one with my
partners moved around the country
we rented machines with purchase made
he already had his most  r delivered from the
butcher shop we hired 15 people
and march fourteenth to
april 14th on sundays i and my wife
packed the last pallets in the cold store
and delivered on the 15th
however
is coming to an end with an order from
all the leap of faith and absolutely
and aldi is following  as before a very
important customer to this day of course
not a few anymore but
it would be nice if we hadn't had them would have been
to the company I look at their lives now
and they have
built up blatant companies themselves but also
get to know all kinds of zampanos entrepreneurs
crazy  from berlusconi kirch
now there are probably a
lot more per there is no case for me tapie i
think i name there were already a few
robert louis dreyfus one of my best
friends
such questions who was a by-election from
this whole ranks of the legends the
most impressive for you say that  was a
real box, well, you've already named a
few industrial
ones  t i also have an
incredible number of more children i have tim
höttges miracle telekom the people to
diekmann from the allianz we have
today the first since the advantage of bavaria
that you are not as a
business partner but also there is
also part of it  or dr winter
coming so many problems we have now
but he was an unbelievable
businessman yes
but let's talk about the
exotic he would say that was robert
louis dreyfus yes
that owner yes
that was that was it was also such a
handshake quality  yes if berlin
wants my night we had the game
and then we both
stood at the other hotel after undocking
the curtain came summer hole and then he
stood with his reception from the
painter great hotel quellenhof is
yes he has that in the promise  for the drivers
there is that one
yes but that was one of
those and i have to say mittrup i
experienced unbelievable things and church
i have
too
although he has seen little but we
had we had interestingly
while rath we have i saw him three
four five times so not at all
no no no and from the current
actor perez is the smart madrid well
he is
a figure there is
little in the
context of manchester united was the former owner
of manchester united like this because
he can clearly we have
known all along the time as the
g14 the we the the  predecessor of this
ech was yes there may that was a
legendary to prove has the whole
european business there was there was the
galliani from ac milan the perez from
the the
berlusconi
berlusconi was there then the sv
real from barcelona
that was another round yes that
it was like three or four times and we
really put football
in the right direction economically
the champions league reorganized put the
usa under pressure  back then we wanted to do
something of our own in europe
and then they gave in
and then did that and that's why i
fail but also just because i
said peres because i thought we were
actually fans
of the european league of a super league for a long
time  more often
at least with everyone i was always in favor of
the best playing against each other
but i was never one who
would have given up the national leagues
that was always there we always had
different opinions with one or the
other of the big ones because we
said so  we cannot be
responsible for the fact that the rest of the
league breaks down and that, according to
the motto, two classics of
harmony,
a very common cause of growth pains in
young companies
is simply growing out of excel a
lot of company projects are started on an excel
basis and if  they can then grow
larger sometime excel
mapping to p  processes and data everything the
company needs with a
meanwhile more and more frequently used
a solution that is then used
means it contains today's partner
centrally written central erp
software that deals precisely with the problems
that can usually no
longer be solved with excel meanwhile
considered  to have what is just in
stock what is no longer which invoices
are open which ones have been paid
to create the connections between
purchasing between logistics and
shipping so all these areas in the
company to connect the processes that
is what erp software typically
does  knows exactly which
goods leave the warehouse serial numbers all these topics
supplies central central comes with over
1000 functions has interfaces to
all common tools
i.e. applications amazon ebay shops opel free and so
on cloud access of course would be
free to test the whole
thing can do that and central point
[music]
like the last one  recently mentioned here from
time to time the colleagues
from vodafone have started a green business
initiative for
business customers around their tariff red
business prime that's the central
tariff that millions of self-employed
entrepreneurs in germany use
and you can now use it completely
act climate-neutral because vodafone
offers an of setting so has
no reduction but at least an of
setting for all the emissions that
arise through this tariff uses
, from the production of the telephone to
the tariff to the telephoning itself
to disposal, so a
huge leap  I think it's a great idea
from vodafone so the buck is there
too is his sign up now for the
red business plan tariff from vodafone
the costs for the first six months
will be taken over completely by vodafone and
then you will say at least immediately
climate-neutral about just like I said of
setting everyone  info at vodafone.de
green owns
m  shouldn't you
rethink now because otherwise
you'd really be left behind or are you going to be compared to
the bundesliga that our
basketball what the bbl is
basketball and the nba that's the
family and all the stars and all the trainers
you can already see them  everyone
behind is big money and if you
're not careful i have the
feeling he knows what and because he knows and
because he sees it in the spanish league
i didn't try half a chance
to save real madrid but as soon as i
build
I don't think
that's for sure that he would save with real madrid because the
problem has already been realized,
something similar to bayern and barcelona we
're the only clubs that are still
clubs run by ev he has
members barcelona has funds
as members say so far
we sometimes controlled
the game without borders he plays he
plays many of the there instead of where where start
the clubs own or olig  archen
and as long as he doesn't bring himself to do it,
which he will probably never
do, he can do another super
league, which won't solve the problem
because little now newcastle
really has the saudis if
at some point they say bye mother has 500
million
then they'll use it  the whole super league
nothing more but you let it be decided first on the
same platform that's a
decision that you can at least
play against them and that you
can do that in the champions league
okay if you still have the chance
so i can only do it for myself  talking i
never want to be responsible that there is
a two class society in the bundesliga one two
clubs that play
in the super league and the rest
play some
what do i know pumpkin capos let's say
i thought about becoming head of the dfl i never thought about it
it still needs a few
days
in wages in an early phase when the
cfl no
that was i wasn't the type of
s  o such a function at first i was really good
here as
chairman of the board
i have never applied boss has the floor
reports
then i would have taken on all these
tasks he did very well
uefa fifa a lot of meetings a lot of
days  and hours that's not my
world if after two three hours in
some cream and then i was nervous
yes and if you don't want that
you can say it was a bandage or
according to the dfb or the cases it's not my
world okay what what can you  i
don't know personally about hops texting
but i'm curious but a new
way a woman i find sometimes he is
very interesting what
would make sense maybe to tackle what
would you hope that
this time she also has big
shoes to take over from hans seifert
who i really appreciate, he did a great
job in the for the
bundesliga and there are many, many
tasks, for example the verh  senior to the
dfb there is always something
that can be amiss i just hope that
the dfl will also have an influence that there will
be a reasonable
management structure at the dfb it
is important for german football and for
the bundesliga clubs that the
dfb works because
i have not always seen the national team in that
way, it is a very important
figurehead for german
football and if it is managed as badly
as it has sometimes happened in the
past 20 years,
then fc bayern had an impression
you have the bundesliga  -
have football lumps in
which it is difficult that means that the
internal relationship with the DFB is to be overturned is
an issue and
creating structures that
the only ones have to develop football
together so that we have a
chance against the other big
countries in Europe if I  christian
seifert one was from bayern i
made him an offer yes yes as karl hopfner
dama  When we left I
spoke to him and I would have
done it immediately but he wanted and what you
now
I don't know he is for every office
in major sport is the way you know
what you draw what what island so if
you  let someone say what is special
and what is looking at people
who decided for me as well as me for karl
they have decided for me
what does his think is good now
what are they looking at so if there is a
successor like that obviously looks like
they  successor
would have solved well now in addition to football
expertise what had not forgotten
after all adidas was chairman of the
board and very important function
here now too but you don’t have to
discover yet that was somehow a
bit of a review we with adidas
already had great achievements is
very important there  one who
works in the group then works in football
but you
're right, of course
, it has become flexible  El er, he did
something else before and he has worked himself
incredibly into the matter,
although he doesn't actually
correspond to my hovering booty scheme now because he was
n't big football, but there are, as
always, one of those exceptions who made
it, who say the idea
interests  of football
and he got to grips with the subject
very quickly and in the
end understood exactly what he was
talking about
but in general there are and which
attributes indicate that i look
at people that are important to me because they
believe in me i think so too  a few
had already knew afterwards didn't fit
so we once gave ourselves the tiger of the
world and that's always right exactly
but what is what is because that's
a lot of gut feeling if
i would i never hire someone
after a
letter of application  so we wouldn't always
say we're called your name how old and
there you're missing
and because I mö  echt
so my quote is not so
bad in the decisions who was
the biggest hit in hindsight probably
say who moved the most so also in the
club or probably who leveraged the most
say
the topic so absolutely but I think
if you think about it how  how many
people we
train station was a brilliant brilliant infection
that was, for example, one
we put in an ad there
were 400 applicants and then we had
a man read everything himself then
hired a personnel agency
out of the 400 the last ten
to choose yes and the one who does
n't know anything about football you have
advertised the whole world you can understand
and to keep the goods yourself and
then we met
the last ten people
personally and interestingly enough we were
almost all there he
is moving yes  and it was an ingenious
but also here a counter that yes yes
yes I warned him once while playing golf
he was he vorsta  And since
I'll say it, I think the Bavarian
state exhibition does that
, they seriously considered
me becoming
a player's advisor. There was also a period when they even
threatened Bayern here if I did
n't get it right, which advisor
and he didn't do that at all  where
do you want to go with the money i can say that would be when
they become that of 80 years
that it has become unbelievable yes she is
but in front of
the old ones can play football
and how they all do it can be
so you as a player ready there was something
let's do your high school exams together
but that's a risk now of course but
probably that you
'll still have 10 20 subject in january 70 don't forget that 20 years ago we had a career that we
might have become even more
successful economically but not  what
do you think player
consultants would also get goosebumps entering a stadium
and everything red and white in your eyes
I don't think there's
no price for that, so that we also built a
bit of that life's work for
Bavaria and to be
loved here and by java and and you
won't believe what I've been
experiencing about everyday things
recently  back there it is so
hoeneß i'm from halle
i want you to play at a
benefit game i
'm no longer responsible but the father
very much
that you don't believe what i'm experiencing
you believe and for that there are
so many beautiful ones  experiences
yes or is she once written in a
report i called
someone in
oberstaufen yes you are from the fan club yes
and grandma is 90 from the chairman of the board
of
fendi around chairman and you before
the picture sit do something again
yes what then uli  hoeneß
can so i called the name she is really coming
when did you realize that the
person is a brand so give fc
bayern as like but m  meanwhile i
would say in germany you have
a name for people who are well known on
the level like mrs merkel or hummer
is not always easy i think
i see i think that but that's the way it is
but i really never
worked artificially on it i said
now i have to do it
to achieve that but i have i
think i'm proud of it i was always
myself all the difficulties are
my son so now i've spoken vegan again for a short july
so everything
shuts down i don't have to die again now
shitstorm being full of all
these but i can't get out of my
skin ordering them and
when i go
somewhere i try to express my opinion and if i'm supposed to
beat around the bush all the time
and say yes actually
could be like that  Of course you can be that too
, but if you don't see it that way
then you can also have other senses. I
say you can see it that way if d
I don't give a damn
if the topic fits or not I have the feeling that until now the
tax problems were also on the
way more and more a political figure
agrees I very much regret that because
it made it clear that
nothing was possible in this direction anymore because I am me
Yes, at that time one of them wanted to go, I
was just a few, but if I have any plans today, I
always say the highest and
in a certain way I
always understand, although I think it's a
shame because I think
I do  touched everything i paid my
taxes paid
the interest went to jail
but still something sticks
and i can't argue that away
there's no doubt about it
although i say i
get approval from a lot of
people i've never been to  I've seen
this in life, anyway,
it's going to the top now that I'm big here, for example,
a policy doesn't come out k  could this
work started there is a manslaughter argument
bottom is in
landsberg but it would have been without the goal of
getting him involved and but
i would have i would have raised my voice more
often because i think more
people who are independent and who are able
to
speak out
need to speak out  because we now have
such a new generation in our society that also has an
opinion
, well, uses the emigs and if I
don't lean out the window and
thanks to this shitstorm, the advantage for
mine is I don't read,
so you could understand how  i always tell the
people what i'm going to say again can
it be a hundred times now implores me
anonymously or what's
inside what i answer he's
one writes a sensible letter
with your address and
cell phone number then there are many people who
will call you back i'm like that  teaches then
comes anonymous call
this prevents
what is there the giant is so i
first of all he is calm and i think that will be
so if
someone writes me a reasonable letter with good arguments a
constant call back is a little bit
what the media will do in the end you are
also a figure in the media world because you
understood that perfectly like the
media  work what you just have to
do that the now that also has
such big problems in the
current time some digital world
the upheaval of the media the whole publishers
that used to be big also titles went
away so sooner because I know a
big story  in the star also the star back
then when the unveiling was given that
was meanwhile it's been
read a lot less she didn't want me because he didn't want me
but there were a few
editors there not to disturb them
but many others in
general so that it's also looked at
big daily newspaper for me that was something the
problem speed is more important than content
and that's a big problem
get your cell phone out  Whether they're true or not,
I think that many editors
accuse him of noticing even when
it's wrong and it used to be different
because I can't imagine 19 bands
hildebrand was the cabaret
artist's brother who was head of
sports when he  wrote the article
fc bayern talked to
him and the
trainer and they went to the beetle
then he went to the beetle and
asked himself what you ate
because he also wanted the dessert
that was that there they still had time
to  research but today you
have everything figured out first of all and if you are
no longer forced
to write the watch or
to carry
it correctly, it is important that you have the report as to whether it is correct and
that is why with the stuff and
I want to  I don't want to have anything to do that's
why I read a lot of daily newspapers
I come at the weekend the three-
hour newspaper it
's every day but sit faz
we  lt on sunday
euro on sunday very important very good
newspaper the food newspaper of
course brings erich to life comes on
friday and and everything is possible so that
is however nevertheless the world is
changing so sees the changed already
strong so the editions go back
now no longer reaches that  a lot of people
like before i hope is yes that i will
do something again at some point but
structurally always mine it is not
not not foreseeable my yard
hope dies last
is that for you meanwhile we also see a
lot of what was pushed forward
what was massively there now  is there entertainment in the
bundesliga, like it was back
then, it was
different back then in 17, there was a very critical
look at football and only football now there
is a lot of entertainment
, you also have that in entertainment because we
the people that is also interesting in the
past  was after the war,
people were all in the process of reconstruction but
now that the social stru  our culture is
relatively high, most
people don't know how well to
pay and now they all want to be saved
, played and
football is a very important thing, but
that at the end of the day or does it go further
with the entertainment factor, now the
discussion  you should also set up
a kind of super bowl event in germany
was the feeling i have
nothing against it so herding it's always
always always
good i mean when you consider that
you made it out of the super
bowl because the event is
me  always available for every idea
but in the end it has to do the thing namely
keep football in bremen just to keep
saying so that you said again i did
something new again is crucial but
i say i will even if i
sell him the amount that is in the bottom
right yes
that  is deciding where are you
currently watching football if you are now even
more difficult i can do
that by the way that i find netflix and stuff
but so it's a mush and that sony
but it's but of course i watch
basketball i'm a big basketball
fan last night i sent
manni milan against the french like the will of the
voters or something like that should
be removed but yes with the magenta
you don't know that  all games
but it comes at some point only there only
a European wanted at the moment only
European at but it doesn't come
yet there comes now the nfl are often
so close
comes there
but I have
to but then of course you have to
look it up or summarize I am
for example big golf schau will
also be a player himself until 2 o'clock in the morning yes
but not good unfortunately but it's that
we catch a cookie he usually
lonely at 9 o'clock because of the time difference and if then
justine thomas against dustin johnson has to
set power option frames there
you look, you have to
look who wins what what you
look back now when they say they have
thanks for that  s jobs are allowed to experience so much in
retrospect something was then like the 23
moment to say that simply can’t be
paid for that were perhaps
the absolute career highlight for me now
not only as a player can complain becomes world champion
i think that that was
particularly interesting way environment
bavarian food  super but even nicer
was winning the first
european cup of national champions in
74 because we had to play a
replay against
atletico he if you think about it
we were in brussels and playing
there we got double the
last minute of extra time shoot
11 no fresh underpants
no one thought you
would play again on friday yes and then
the next day we were broken we
trained in brussels on thursday when
she was there there was crippled against against
seriously ill
we couldn't even get up it was over
that is  summer were german champions
but we were all and then you play
120 m  minutes and then training was in
brussels the next few days when you saw the
training you thought that
doesn't exist and the next day
we did and that was my
best game i think i'm
hungry in 2002 we cleaned up the 40 and
i can get my head around that  i was completely
exhausted but in the cabin i had things that
were i if i could stop the world
now yes that was
sporty and otherwise you have of
course experienced a lot yes well as i
mean there are the famous pictures where
you with the  bayern creates therefore
own but what which game or
what moment already in the champions
league 2001
because against
walesa was in the yes and then what was
very emotional for me because i had
to go to jail shortly afterwards was
winning the champions league in
wembley  but
but 13 then it was clear the process was coming
and i knew it was it was very
emotional
one of the crass moments i think when you
follow them like that  it was in the
documentation about bastian
schweinsteiger that he thought of
you after recruiting you graf should
i tell you
there was there i was a prison yes and
i was also the spokesman for these
prisoners in i
remember many older ones in bh spittal  people and i
said
the cell was always locked
i think at half past
nine and i had applied that we
can watch this game together
we are like 10 12 people was rejected
so i say all alone there in my
cell
and then this emotional game and
Normally nobody wants to watch the
last eight times and then
this neighbor comes and he says bastian that
I still get goosebumps from all of them today, by the
way, I would like to remind someone
without whom we are not here today,
maybe we have
forgotten another topic, which is also true  they distinguish
what the feeling is missing in the
if you looked for it understand we
understand you made it this
fami  liar you have to be we don't
even have tension power structures environment
cities that are important but somehow
manage to create the family
aura obviously that
something like this is coming it's not because
you transferred a lot of money
but it's because he  apparently appreciates himself
as a family
person and many others say that's
the way it is somehow
what not at all that is that is my
character and it i am a
family person and am and i have
always tried to show this sense
for the family in this case too  to transfer to fc bayern
and everyone who works here and
especially the players i see as
part of the family and i was
always there for them day and night
i can remember when michael
sternkopf, especially at 2
o'clock drove through a traffic light when it was red and
an accident escape he called me
at 2 o'clock at night increase is mistress of
the traffic light ha  be i both for what should
i do i have to
call the police first and where are you there and
i will come if you
set up at two in the morning and helped him and
get rid of hatred and so there are
1000 she also
referred to questions like  he like that
he wasn't just because but he was
a person i could rely
on and he knew he could rely on
me yes and i always gave the
players the feeling if they're at the
top then i'm not
100 they will  on the shoulder head if
you scored five goals but if
one had torn the cruciate ligament and was
operated on the next morning i know that i
have all that or i also
extended contracts contracts extended night
shortly after the operation
to give just this feeling and also
sometimes  been disappointed but by
someone but offered him i have so
much horny little it can little if my knowledge of human nature
is good but
clearly have the whole story s  ie also
extremely involved the group that yes he was
simply ill and that was that of
course it was a drama 40 talent let's
say as means just before he stopped
for a training day dubai and every
evening every evening at 10:30
am called me
barrios i have to  talk to me talk
and then i'm also in the room
goes the evening but not
anymore you have to know about that
i think they had 20 million for the huge sum
but i think i'm on hand
for 15 million off so that's a real
risk that was the biggest loss of money
for a player we ever had but
he can't help it that
cost a whole 150 million now
as bayern you don't have to dare to take
risks like you did back then
now
maybe holland gave their okay then
120 to dortmund  or 150
calculable risks you have to do
but no harakiri and then 220 is
that I don't know I now know the
total in the mo  ment if you
always have to see the overall package it's
not just about the transfer fee it's about the
basic salary it's about manager
demands came I hear are relatively high
so in that respect you simply have to see it
as the overall package and then the
club has to decide that is imminent
we have to discuss that in the supervisory board
, but i know that there
is nothing concrete on
the table at the moment, so it is still
relevant. the question does not
have to be if i have always
said if i was convinced,
then i am  also taking big
risks that can also go wrong
who is planing where chips are falling it's
like that or why is it
like that in germany there's always this
discussion about the cabin and that
has to be fair and they all have to
earn money now, the top earners  all 20
and those below must have a
hierarchy one should perhaps say as a Bavarian
at least I have ma  l was a 40
or 50, he gets it somewhere
else and then you can buy the club
as a special at the kiosk after a very short time
, but it's also common after the usa
there's an advantage becker
gets 25 30 there's somehow
there even had to  physically save your ass
in this game and then get
but 100,000 that's about it, the
cornerback not only have the 2 wonderful
and the t receiver is exchanged on 81 m
but that's football you
can also laugh I'm there for hygiene if
if if the  disc the discrepancy
between the best top earner and the
50 percent that won't
work in the long run
what's coming in the next few years the
highest will be 70 did you say what
do you still want to do i want the supervisory board
are you still there is there still
some kind of foundation commitment we
have to  introduce yourself during the day
read a lot except at the weekend what's up here
plan i'm available i'm available to all
sorts of people for discussions
v  help my son if he has a
problem in his company if he
sometimes you need one or the
other conversation or a visit from
a buyer but rarely or
however you can you don't travel like
that
if you because if if if if you have
then  has a problem so you can call
something or even
come by and i will come by here
so that we
are apart i i move the
fusion ii to impose my opinion
but you all know when you need advice
and a good one at that  meant
completely without ulterior motives then you
know what i think not the soldiers too
faster than we have our
lives they gave it full throttle in the totally
fast lane until now
now i have been out of
business for two years yes i look like
an old man  man no so i have to
say
the hope that nothing is preserved like
that everything is fine
yes okay i'll go through it first i have to wait a
long time al  so much time for the answers
and for the digressions was a lot of
fun i have to say i don't have to say
what's going on in the guy are but it was it
was just entertaining and that was
it was it wasn't they didn't
try to tease me  to take a
lot of respect
off one or the other moderator
didn't hold out either but
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr